we are in Ireland we're in Dublin when
Trinity College who and were standing
outside as you can see the physical
laboratory the physics department here
in Trinity College Dublin were Ernest
Walton many would say I think with very
little argument the most important or
the most famously most prestigious Irish
physicist has been because he he split
the atom the first person who split the
Atome was the first person along with
croc raft to verify that YZ equal MC
squared is right he paved the way for
nuclear energy paved the way for our
understanding of the nucleus he did at
the time or if what was just a
remarkable achievement which was to
target the nucleus to target the nucleus
with protons on that nucleus that at the
time it was said it was like trying to
target a gnat in a Cathedral to train
and get down because the nucleus is 10
so a hundred thousand times smaller than
the atom so you really train a fire in
that it's not what they were very keen
to see it's splitting the atom is sort
of easy what they were doing was
splitting the nucleus and they were
finding that nucleus which is embedded
at the heart of the atom he he went to
work with Rutherford in the cabinets
laboratory in Cambridge and that's why
he did it is experiment he built up
accelerators particle accelerators the
first generations particle accelerators
came from Cockroft
and Walton they work very close together
cut off more on the theoretical side
Walton was an incredibly talented
experimentalist extremely good with his
hands
working with bits of copper and metal
and glass and apparently key aspects of
the kit were held together with
plasticine so we're going to go inside
into this wonderful historic building
we're going to meet somebody called
professor Ignatius McGovern who was not
only had the honour of having an office
beside Walton was actually had the
dishonor or the opposite of honor of
actually being the external examiner for
my PhD thesis so he knows exactly how
little physics I actually know so let's
go in and see ad this this actually is
where Waltons office was so as you can
see obviously there's a different
incumbent in there now
fortunately we can't get in which is a
bit frustrating but we're going to go
and see you again oh well this used to
be the the the big teaching lab in in
this building this building is from 1905
so it was a really a modern building of
its time and this is where the
practicals were carried out in a very
large room but it has been to some
extent carved up a little bit for
offices and in behind me directly a hind
me is a very famous office this is a
professor Waltons office in his
retirement 20 is a strong tradition of
keeping its scholars if you like staying
on after they've retired
contributing in big and small ways but
being about the place well - my office
is in the corner here also part of this
carve up but it's a very sort of flimsy
carve up so you can actually
conversations akari through these walls
we have to be very careful by what we
say legally when you can hear everything
that's around noises for example at one
stage we the 20 college didn't have many
many phone lines in this building and we
shared a phone line professor Walton I
the chair and whoever got to the phone
first would be the person who answered
before so I would Casely hear him saying
he's not here you would accidentally be
sharing phone calls with with Walton yes
it was amazing yes well he was getting
me he was he was getting a better class
of phone call here's a great great story
about Walton not our genial host
professor Ignatius McGovern told us just
just when we arrived here so Walton was
lecturing at the board one day in this
theater in this very very theater and
was writing on the board something and
he heard this click click click click
and what had happened is that somebody
back in the audience had dropped a ball
bearing and the ball bearing was rolling
down these these stairs and so Walton
finished whatever he was writing and
then he walked over here he picked up
the ball
wherever it was he walked back up these
stairs and he placed on an exactly the
desk that it came from and he said to
the person sitting in the end I
whispered to him don't do that again
obviously he came to the hops of the
ball bearing down the steps while he was
doing probably quite complex derivation
on the board at the same time I love
that story but the great thing about
walton is all that all the biographies
you read of walton a wonderful scientist
but really really humble really didn't
you know you know strive to take the
credit for things actually had to be
foresight into the limelight but at the
same time generally you find when people
are sort of perhaps humble like that
they tend to be quite introvert in which
room but what was a really phenomenally
good lecturer really really real good
and generations of students attest to
that and he was incredibly well loved
here and the humility of the man I think
was you know people would come into the
staff room in the common room here
Walton would be sitting in the corner
and people couldn't believe that a
person they were talking to you know was
split the atom you know he was the guy
along with Cockroft and he was you know
he didn't let all that go to his head
well I think the first you know the
first contact with them and first
meeting him was was a little bit
overwhelming but he came to coffee every
every morning like everybody else and
after a few weeks and I kind of got used
to the idea that ETS as we called him
was was just part of the part of the
part of the crowd or he was also known
as the wee prof that's just a faction
yes he was yes he was he wasn't at all
it wasn't at old man you know he had
been the prof and then he had retired
and someone else became the prof and so
he became the we prof okay so other than
trying not to overhear his telephone
conversations like what I couldn't help
hearing are the little noises that were
coming through the wall
because ETS was an experimentalist and
he'd like to tinker with bits and pieces
of apparatus in particular old pieces of
apparatus that he used in demonstration
lectures and these often involved
electrostatic generating machines
machines like the the Wimshurst machine
something that you sir this could you
propelled around and it picked up
electrostatic charge and created a spark
so you could I could hear this sort of
whirring and then this spark the crack
of the spark well I suppose what we're
doing we're inching towards the this
idea of writing a poem about ets Walton
and I that's one of the things I do here
in physics I write poetry sometimes
about science sometimes about other
things and so I was asked to write a
poem on the occasion of the plaque that
you may have seen on the building
downstairs
commemorating ETS Walton and so thinking
about what should I write about you
might say may be a difficult subject
because he was a very quiet unassuming
man but what I hit upon for my poem were
to a combination of two things one was
the little noises coming through the
wall you know the rule smack of the of
the discharge from the Wimshurst machine
and an even bigger noise if you like
which of course was the awarding of the
Nobel Prize and in that context the idea
of splitting the atom and when it was
announced that they had split the atom
there was a cartoon in one of the
British newspapers showing the boys with
a gigantic mallet splitting the atom so
the noise and the combination of that
cartoon became a kind of a theme on on
she liked on hammers and the poem is
called hammer and spark welder in my
office which is next door to ets Waltons
office this is the the wall the flume
a flimsy wall hammer and spark not the
miss proclaiming the glorious news nor
the cartoon mullet of the first atom
smashers nor the claw dismantling the
Timbers for reuse nor the gavel
expanding the laws of student physics
nor the sledge on plowshares for the
global village listen a gentle topping
the pain of the silversmith the
scintillations
that be token faith